comienzo por preguntarle por el inicio
de toda esta historia en qué consiste
entonces esta plataforma qué tipo de
información va a proporcionar y cómo se
alimenta esta plataforma
hola santiago muchas gracias por la
invitación al espacio sí pues la
plataforma ciudadana de fosas es un
esfuerzo que en realidad venimos
haciendo diferentes organizaciones y
academia méxico desde el año 2015 lo que
hemos hecho es sistematizar información
de fosas clandestinas que vienen de
fuentes oficiales y nueve oficiales por
ejemplo fiscalías o procuradurías
estatales de los 32 estados del país la
fiscalía general de la república y
también la prensa escrita nacional y
local el objetivo es reunir la mayor
cantidad de información sobre fosas
clandestinas para poder tener un
diagnóstico sobre la magnitud del
fenómeno no entonces pues a lo largo de
los años hemos
publicado diferentes productos de
investigación sin embargo ahora
decidimos hacer esta plataforma
interactiva que pueda ser accesible al
público y que se pueda consultar de
diferentes formas no le las las personas
pueden consultar cuántas fosas
clandestinas se han localizado por
ejemplo por parte de la prensa o también
comparar con las cifras oficiales y por
los datos también están abiertos para su
descarga para que las personas también
puedan por ejemplo auditar los o
utilizarlos para otras investigaciones
señor ruiz esta plataforma es una
respuesta en cierta manera a la
impunidad que hay en mexico en torno a
varios casos que están todavía sin
esclarecer también a la lentitud de las
investigaciones por parte de las
autoridades oa qué responde
sí correcto el objetivo principal es
contrarrestar un poco al vacío de
información que hay por parte de las
autoridades sobre todo hay que recordar
que en mexico en 2018 entró en vigor la
ley general en materia de desaparición
forzada y desaparición cometida por
particulares esta ley crea por ejemplo
muchos bueno instituciones y programas
de política pública y también
herramientas de información dentro de
estas herramientas se contempla por
ejemplo la creación de un registro
nacional de fosas clandestinas y puestos
comunes que tendría que ser llevado por
las autoridades para justo e integrar
toda esta información y que se pueda
utilizar por ejemplo para generar
investigaciones y también posibles
programas de búsqueda el problema es que
pues ya tres años de la implementación
de la ley general pues también no
contamos con este registro nacional de
fosas clandestinas por parte de las
autoridades no después el objetivo de la
plataforma es poder contrarrestar un
poco esto y puedes poner a la
disposición esta información para las
propias autoridades para colectivos de
familiares en búsqueda y para la
sociedad en general para conocer la
magnitud del fenómeno
estos datos pueden utilizarse por
ejemplo para
programas de búsqueda y exhumación en
méjico